[Music]
hey guys I think you know how we all
have like our favorite childhood snacks
wouldn't it be so fun if we had one that
was a grown-up size now that we're older
and bigger with Easter coming up I was
thinking it would be such a fun idea to
make giant sized kinder eggs it's just a
cute little treat that I had when I was
a kid as you guys know I mainly just do
food stuff in order to replicate this
and really make it look like the real
thing I enlisted some help and this is
where Turin high turin is on the Nifty
team she is amazing at arts and crafts
and just anything crafting this is so
much expectation I have so much faith in
you I think we can make this happen what
do you say giant kinder egg let's do it
yes let's start with making the giant
chocolate egg
so the kinder egg we're gonna do is
actually the Kinder Surprise which is
the international version comes in an
egg with a little capsule holding the
toy inside we couldn't find it because
we're in America where the actual Kinder
Surprise is banned what I need to do is
to make a chocolate egg that has white
chocolate on the inside and then put a
toy in it I started looking up egg
moulds on the internet and I found a
bunch but they weren't really that big
until I found this place called lilac
chocolates one of the oldest chocolate
shops in Manhattan they have a giant
like actual giant chocolate egg I'm
gonna go to their shop and make the
chocolate egg with them we are here at
lilac chocolates
I'm here with master chocolatier Anwar
he's been doing this for 30 years I've
been doing this for like 30 seconds you
said you would help me with making this
giant kinder egg first we have to make a
joke for reference this is the giant egg
mold we make it in dark chocolate after
we take the shell out we can cover line
it up with white chocolate inside we
said dark chocolate because even though
kinder egg is normally milk chocolate
and we're doing this for grown-ups and I
prefer dark chocolate so we're gonna go
with dark let's do it yeah now we're
gonna fill it up with chocolate takes
about 20 pounds of chocolate 20 pounds
about between somewhere between 15
together
how did you know that there was 20
pounds in there do you just feel it you
know
oh my god it's just one new demo first
coding
every time you turn it around you get a
little time and we put it in the fish we
wait until it's cool now we need to tell
it so to make sure it comes out to
pieces back in the fridge feeding off so
now we just need 30 minutes right it
needs to sit here about 30 minutes it's
so this is how big it is it's like half
of my body
Wow now we can afford the white
chocolates inside you could go as thick
as you want and then we'll turn it out
like this what you do good since we
qualify their business time a lot of
chocolate swirl it first here we go
oh it's so warm
[Music]
no waste no but it's in the fish five
minutes maybe 10 minutes Moscow so now
we wait
10 minutes 10 10 excited okay how's this
for a massive kinder egg make sure this
edges are set you know so we can put it
together come by little come break it no
I'm gonna put the toy I couldn't find a
giant capsule you know how they do it in
kinder eggs that's why I use tissue
paper please forgive me Tarn will be
revealing this later can you tell what
it is
we're not gonna open it again no right
yeah until the end of the video we're
not gonna open it again this is the
moment this is it
the doors will be sealed we kind of get
some chocolate you can eat glue it
together you have to be a little quick
because otherwise the chocolate will dry
and won't stick together really quick
that's how much my mother
why am I so nervous perfect no hairdo
mean well now in opinion this part
[Music]
now with Klamath yeah there we go
few minutes yeah a few minutes it's like
a Dragon's egg this is like even bigger
than I imagined
I'm scared I don't want to break it we
came so far there go oh my god is this
an egg makeover
all right well this is the giant kinder
egg it's done the challenge is to bring
it back safe and sound and not crack it
let's see if we can make that happen
here we go
[Music]
twenty-something pounds
[Music]
I'll hand it off to you now you got it
up
[Music]
egg is here and when I sign up for this
I was not expecting it to be this big
you know it's gonna shoot like a really
cute top down shots so this is like all
you can see Hey I think the first thing
we should do is find out how much foil
we'll need to Victor love guys I need k9
Ashley you guys what if I still wrap it
up and she doesn't know do you think we
can put it back together
it's fine don't worry we can fix that
don't worry okay I think this is the
bottom this is the edge this this this I
don't even know what goes where we
should turn off the lights work on this
off-camera start it stuff unless you
have the rule hi we have a little bit of
an accident yeah just a little crack
would it be possible to borrow the mold
from you
it's really sad we tried we got the
whole village in here what I decided was
tinfoil and imagination whatever was in
that egg I just don't know what it is
I've started just wrapping it in bits
and pieces of tin foil until I think
I've achieved the desired egg shape she
said a fun montage of me creating this
eggs
grab some fabric over it
have you guys watched any BuzzFeed video
where they try and they fail and they
just stop should we be the first
everyone in the office is aware that the
egg has been broken
except for Inga so here it is not the
egg I'm actually going to come clean to
her I feel like this was like our first
big collaboration and we've been talking
about this she's gonna be really
disappointed hope she doesn't cry oh no
because I did I'm gonna go bring her in
no don't bring in Inga
okay hi this was something I tried to do
okay and this is what we've been hiding
from you hey I put the egg on the table
and it fell off the table it ran off the
table there that's what happened
it broke pretty much immediately when I
started shooting is it just towels yeah
this is the eggs all of it No
[Music]
all right round two
second egg let's go yep I don't trust
myself so I'm gonna let Ingo put the
eggs away oh my god much like what
happened last time let's carry it back
into this we're not gonna take it out of
the plastic okay this is like the last
layer of protection no pressure
we have to egg bag it already started
cracking so we're in a bit of a time
crunch so what I'm gonna try to do now
is create this giant piece of wrapping
paper that we can then put on the egg
we need 35 by 35 inches of foil to cover
the entire egg anything between 35 to 40
inches will probably be safer that
should be large enough to cover that egg
we can have to prime the surface if you
just paint it straight on to foil
it's just smudges if you put a little
bit of a priming paint it will actually
stick a little more we've applied the
spray paint and we're gonna start
drawing print it out a template promote
even more templates using a paint marker
that's pretty good duh there we go just
gonna leave it empty for now boom done
with the first part of it time for
painting we're just gonna use normal
acrylic paint for this step one trick I
learned is that if you put a little bit
of dish soap into the paint the paint
will actually come out looking like a
little more vibrant get started
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
pretty much done painting let this
completely dry and then start painting
in the actual lettering and then we'll
wrap the egg yeh I'm using these paint
markers feel like it might actually look
better unlike white so I've gone in and
painted all the letters white so much
better
[Music]
it looks so much I think I think then we
should go ahead and wrap it will call
Ingo over we're gonna wrap it and you
know this video will be over let's do it
all right
her should probably wrap the real egg in
like a clean piece of foil first
[Music]
you want to hold it like that and I
should bring the real thing
[Applause]
pretty big it's sitting on his own video
started off the day as people who have
never made a giant kinder egg and we're
ending the day it's people we are just
so glad we were able to get to this
point it took two eggs a lot of Tears a
lot of sweat a lot of time your arm you
are amazing you are a wizard thank you
we're gonna open this you can just
gently Oh pry this open sir let us know
what else you want us to make you know
and each other's necks you want but big
but not too big so go stressful we're
gonna eat it
yeah let's eat it Spencer's mom cuz that
to slow everyone eat some chocolate is
it really good yes
[Music]
[Applause]